romain bouteille est ce que ça n'est pas
trop difficile ou trop pénible d'être
pour l'éternité le père éternel du café
thé à pascal maintenant chaque fois
qu'on parle de vous c'est brest merci
c'est pareil dieu merci c'est pas vrai
je suis pas responsable de ces horreurs
il ya eu confusion temps et vous étiez à
la création quand même quelque part mais
oui mais à l'envers
quelle cellule fils de gaffer c'est le
principe de base qui était absolument
inadmissible du café de la gare c'était
qui était interdit de choisir les
acteurs qui seraient pris de les punir
et est interdit d'interdire
on pouvait pas les virées non plus et
c'est eux qui avaient construit le t1 le
proprio donc c'est cette trempe là il
n'avait pas choisi et ils ont rien
appris
j'ai appris il en a pris sans punition
est un peu simili en tant que patron
rayé alors c'est bien sûr sa 2d des
vedettes mais c'est le contraire d'une
école vous mais moi je suis pas perdu
tout j'ai uniquement juriste et je
veille à ce que la loi soit respectée
il est interdit d' empêcher quelqu'un de
faire comme il entend faire sur scène
ces séquences 7 c'est rationnel
oui c'est ça c'était en santé un petit
peu que c'était dans la foulée de hao
68,1 le discours lincou venez de tenir
là une définition ou du café théâtre
banon aucune ne sai a que les
journalistes vont faire est-ce que c'est
forcément de la création collective
aussi non à pas exactement non non non
c'est il ya des petits pas chez nous moi
je parle pas du café théâtre en général
je peux parler que de chez nous parce
que ailleurs ça rien oir ya des riens
qui se compare pas donc si vous avez un
peu ce que vous avez fait des petits
quand même mais je sais pas des bons
petits d'abord les petits j'ai fait ce
qu'on connaît ils sont dans le cinéma
art typiquement industriels c'est comme
si c'était dans une banque
il ya pas de quoi être fier de les avoir
faits voyez c'est faudrait plutôt pas le
raconter
et en plus je ne sais pas faire je veux
pas qu'on me colle sur le dos rond
d'autre part dans les boîtes dans les
cafés-théâtres est-ce qu'on inclut dans
le café est valable le porno on dit tu
as que c'est tout à fait du café
est-ce qu'on inclut le purement
commerciale est-ce qu'on inclut pas dans
l'existence d'un endroit où simplement
le pâton et acheteurs de spectacles et
revendeurs nos fabricants est ce que
doit alors on veut pas ça va et des
milliers de qualité où ça qu'ils sont
pas les mêmes dans chaque
en règle générale est ce que c'est du
théâtre au rabais souvent très souvent
pour des raisons économiques
tu t'es est moins chère la moins chère
est en outre moins cher au rabais il ya
une nuance
oui parce que on a aussi du théâtre en
rabais très très cher je pense à des
gens comme maréchal alors la plus
théâtrale est extrêmement cher chéreau
vous dites ça vous faire plaisir aux
lyonnais je sais pas moi je veux voir
une pièce de mach 6 avait été la même
pièce les mêmes acteurs dans une petite
boîte équipe à dépenser un centime
on aurait dit formidable sont très bien
de son poêle à partir de 2 3 milliards
en faudrait faire faudrait trouver
quelque chose pas une pièce de chez pas
qui tient pas la distance pas pape mais
vous en étiez cheyrou la continuité il y
en ad'autres belle catégorie théâtre au
rabais je savais plus qui fait mais je
sais plus qui fait mais il est probable
je crois qu'effectivement ça a
certainement du talent mais pas assez
pour bouffer je crois
entre 12 et 13 milliards pour l'année
chaque spectateur qui rentrera chez lui
sera aura coûté 90 francs pour entrer
est ce que vous vous souriez faire avec
12 ou 13 millions vous avez entendu
tonneaux je crois pas je crois pas
d'abord le maître se serait pas moi
parce que le contrôle et vient de
l'émanation des milliards il est bien
sûr il ya un metteur en scène et tout
mais il est choisi par les milliards oui
il peut être très bien d'ailleurs il
peut être très intelligent mais enfin il
faut qu'ils aient à l'égard des gens
d'argent une tolérance ou même
merveilleuse soyez il faut que et c'est
pour ça qu'il ya tellement d'homosexuels
ce qui est beaucoup plus facile pour un
homosexuel de supporter des gens de
finances que pour un qui serait artistes
et non homosexuels dont il est supporter
au moins tu haïras c'est beau je veux
dire il a il a la passion que savait
qu'il a une histoire d'amour quelle que
soit la il peut être amoureux de
quelqu'un qui va lâcher les milliards et
il peut même avoir un esprit c'est pas
péjoratif à se dit il peut même avoir un
esprit de courtisanes c'est à dire que
on croit que les courtisanes sont
cyniques et ne s'intéressent qu'à
l'argent c'est absolument pas vrai une
courtisane est capable de mourir pour
son affreux milliardaire briller elle
aime dire que l'argent représente un
capital de beauté qui est donc son
milliardaire et le voit vraiment beau et
s'il est dans un incendie vous verrez ça
courtisane cynique c'est elle qui va
grimper après adam le feu pour le
chercher au lit et tout ce que vous
venez nous dire n'est absolument pas
animé par un quelconque sentiment de
regret ou deux
blanche et non j'ai un dossier s'est dit
j'ai crevé pour qu'ils aient un
sentiment de revanche pour qu'on puisse
déploré par exemple ne pas avoir de
subventions
il faudra en avoir demandé une enquête
on est pas fou alors quand la lumière se
pose sur vous dites vous bien que il
n'ya rien à faire c'est irrémédiable
c'est le doigt du destin qui vous a
désigné le toit du destin je vous fais
remarquer qu'il repose sur un pied et
qu'il est alimenté par cette que
noirâtre donc quand le doigt du destin
vous désigne rester calme vous prononcer
votre nom et vous me donnez un mot avec
lequel je vous joue la scène de
remplacement pour le site
oui mais le café théâtre alors au jour
d'aujourd'hui tout de même bien que vous
ne voudrez vous reconnaissiez plus dans
la descendance
elle n'a jamais été aussi nombreuses
aussi diverses et on y fourre un peu
tout quand même avouer maintenant non
c'est devenu qui remarquer que avant que
j'étais tout seul à redire du mal que
maintenant tout le monde trouve que
c'est moche et j'ai toujours trouvé ça
moche depuis depuis 69
quand on en est en est nommé café
théâtre dans un journal on essaie
l'humiliation mais on annonce
périodiquement aussi la mort du
café-théâtre uni c'est fini c'est pas
vrai du tout à bâle ce ne peut pas être
fini c'est totalement immortels mais pas
pour des réseaux très très noble non
plus c'est qu'un bonhomme
tout seul peut te bourrer une salle que
le français entier n'est pas garanti de
bouri alors qu'est-ce qui était
économiquement leur rapport ils se
discute pas c'est qu'ils soient bons ou
mauvais le café théâtre
il gagne il il a deux ans d'avancé sur
ses one man show pourquoi on attache
toujours votre nom à la naissance du
café théâtre il ya quand même une raison
aussi le 2e viennent
oui alors il faut à j'avais déjà pas
répondu à ces locations répondait cette
question la mort il a répondu oui mais
vous me faites faire le procès de
l'information ont ça en en octobre ce
prêt ils le font parce que l'information
est standard a pâti au moment où il faut
qu'ils déterminent un chef pour un
phénomène donné comme s'il y en avait de
la même manière il croit que mitterrand
est pour quelque chose dans l'avenir de
la france alors que c'est pas lui c'est
les bureaux c'est l'administration et
elle et les capitalistes et de la même
manière ils font croire n'importe quoi
c'est un consensus
ils sont d'accord l'information elle est
systématiquement fausse c'est pas un
accident tellement qu'elle est folle
comprenez elle et quantitatif on a un
peu de peine à comprendre c'est au même
titre que avant de parler du sort des
juifs faudrait établir qu'ils existent
il n'existe pas en tant que race et on
continue à dire ils ont martyrisé les
alors donc vous refusez l'étoile jaune
du café-théâtre journée qu'on voit là un
voilà chez moi j vous imaginez pas le
tas de connards que peut comporter
le tout peut vous qu'il peut y avoir
dans des genres de cas refléter
exactement le même temps qu'ailleurs
royer
comment être plus méchant ou plus de sid
que romain bouteille un contradicteur
nous a donc paru superflu à vienne
il va sans dire que la sélection ne
présentent comme les années précédentes
d'ailleurs que le nec plus ultra de la
profession
[Musique]
et alors romain bouteille d'être de
toujours assimilé à cette dangereuse
opérations du café théâtre dont je suis
persuadé qu'en même que les historiens
jours vont dire qu'elle a été très
infiltrée donc un voilà complètement
bourré il ya un que sais-je se plante du
seuil est le genre pioupious gérard
depardieu et patrick dewaere oeuvre
alors les berceuses de bernard blier
passe à celles annoncées loi de force
mais aussi des coquilles simplement
sikoti dans un car est grand comme ça
c'est ça le talent alors cela dit qu'on
n'arrive pas à vous d'y soucier de ça
vous vous même vous en vous regrettez
d'eads est complètement associés ça vous
auriez voulu avoir votre votre existence
indépendante être un comédien comme les
autres jouer dans des films ou n'aurait
fait attention à vous vous auriez pas
fait toujours le même personnage non non
non non moi
à voir la situation j'ai et puis le jeu
pointé à 8h30 au maquillage pour tourner
jusqu'à six heures du soir
merci je serais vraiment trop cher
impensable
vous êtes bien compromis quelquefois
aussi les mains oui mais pas plus de 3 4
jours depuis fait fallait ça pour avoir
des sous quoi mais c'est terrible comme
on monte on se demande pourquoi ils font
quoi
au cinéma tous ceux qui sont pas ivre
mort de huit à six heures du soir
pourquoi il suffit side écoute il ya des
raisons vachement simple ils sont en
même temps artiste et il faut qu'ils
obéissent de ça va plus les cracks
vous avez un réveil dans votre panoplie
j'ai l'âme
pourquoi rêvée pour se lever le matin il
fait ce que je dis je le met à sonner à
3 heures de l'après midi qu'un problème
c'est qu'ils me réveille à 3 heures du
matin ces duos de dominer le monde
[Musique]